our series of more perfect union aims to
show what unites us as Americans is far
greater than what divides us today we
bring you the story of Susan Unterberger
she's a 77 year old photographer who
used her inheritance to advance the
careers of female artists without
identifying herself until now the grant
named anonymous was a woman pays homage
to women in art who once believed their
work had more value if their gender was
kept a secret only on CBS this morning
Alex Wagner spoke with hunter Berg and
two of the people she's inspired so this
is the studio that's right you can find
Susan Unterberger work in collections at
some of the country's most respected
museums but it's her effort as an
anonymous benefactor of fellow female
artists that's now brought her the most
acclaimed you have helped over 200 women
in twenty-two years correct how does
that make you feel well it makes me feel
great since 1996 under Berg's grant
anonymous was a woman has given 10
$25,000 awards a year to female artists
over 40 they could be single mothers
there's child care women's work isn't as
his but as often as men's galleries
don't give them shows as often use eum's
don't what I want for my work is that
it's very difficult to describe
Arleen sheket won the award in 2010
being in the world and looking like
you're very successful doesn't mean that
it's not financially a strain and
selling art is hard so you can never
know what to count on after she was
commissioned last year to paint the
official portrait of First Lady Michelle
Obama
artist Amy Cheryl relied on the
anonymous grant to actually complete it
I was like down to my last thousand
dollars and couldn't pay my rent Wow
this grant saved me from being an uber
driver being artist is a very insecure
position not just financially but
emotionally and psychologically yes and
there's a lot of rejection to handle
so I think that the grant actually faces
down some of the insecurities really
it's really intangibles that stick
around the validation and also feeling
part of a community let's talk about
that because yeah this is in fact a
tribe of sisters people didn't know that
until this particular and we've been
accused of being competitive with each
other and mm-hmm at least for myself my
satisfaction was always gained through a
man you know if a man found you worthy
so this is trying to change that do you
think that that is particularly needed
at this moment it's always been needed
and but not particularly now but now as
much as ever what do you think Amy about
the fact that two women Michelle Obama
Susan hunter Berg have played such
pivotal roles in your life as an artist
I can't wait to pay it forward
and I said that - Michelle - I said I
appreciate this this is a gift and I
promise to pay it forward for CBS this
morning Alex Wagner New York and to
think she was just one step away from
being an uber driver right I mean given
the first lady's right right get a sense
of how insecure they are about that next
big project so this is really helpful
what a great story